28 février à l'exception des transports
règles simples entrera en vigueur
impasse pas de masque nous n'imposerons
plus le port du masque dans tous les
lieux fermés soumis aux passes comme les
bars les restaurants les théâtres les
cinémas les musées c'est une contrainte
en moins c'est une liberté en plus et
c'est un moment attendu je le sais par
les français vous le voyez comme nous
nous y étions engagés nous ne prenons
pas une mesure de plus que nécessaire
par un jour de plus que nécessaire c'est
également ce que nous ferons pour le
pass vaccinale pour le port du masque
plus généralement en intérieur dès que
la situation à l'hôpital le permettra
j'avais eu l'occasion de le dire la
semaine dernière je veux le rappeler si
nous avons pu prendre des restrictions
minimale c'est grâce à une couverture
vaccinale maximale et à une part
importante de la population ayant reçu
une dose de rappel près de 38 millions
de français ont reçu une dose de rappel
c'est plus de 70% des adultes